the family of a man shot and killed by a
texas police officer during a mental
health check
is calling for the officer's arrest
doorbell camera video shows what
happened sunday
before officer ronaldo contreras shot
patrick warren
senior who was unarmed officer contreras
is now on administrative leave pending
an investigation
warren's son says his family had called
for help
because warren was having a mental
health emergency
omar villafranca has more on more good
morning
good morning the video which was
released by the family attorney and
looks to be edited
does not show the final shots being
fired and that's why the family wants
the body cam footage from the police
officer released
now keep in mind before this incident
the day before they called and they got
a mental health professional to show up
no problem
but when they called on sunday a colleen
police officer arrived
instead
ring doorbell footage shows officer
reynaldo contreras
knocking on patrick warren's senior's
door a surprise to his family
who had requested help from a mental
health professional
they never told us that one wasn't
available they just sent out a colleen
police officer
patrick warren jr says officer contreras
demeanor towards his family was hostile
so the family asked him to leave but
moments later
he returned and knocked warren senior
answered and stepped
outside with his hands in the air his
son says he noticed a red
dot shining on the door the only reason
we got up and walked to the door
is because we saw an infrared beam from
a taser on the door which concerned us
we heard a pop
we got up we ran to the door by the time
we made it outside
he was my father was on the ground and
that's where everything kind of took
place
the video then cuts to cell phone
footage hey dad sit down
sit down sit down sit down
[Music]
the family stood and watched as officer
contreras
a five-year vet at the department shot
the husband and father of three
in the chest warren was pronounced dead
at the hospital
how quick was all that maybe 20 seconds
lee merritt represents warren's family
if they didn't have a mental health
professional readily available to go see
mr warren
should they have not sent that officer
in your mind no
they if they if they couldn't send
someone
with the training to deal with uh the
crisis that was actually occurring then
it would have been better for them to
send no one at all
and mr warren may be alive that's right
warren jr says his family is still
processing their father's death
including his younger brother who has
down syndrome he's constantly he was
like you know
my father's in heaven and i have to
answer that question
[Music]
a thousand times a day and sometimes he
just breaks down and he just wants to
cry
the killeen police department has handed
the investigation over to the texas
rangers
there's no word on if or when that
police body cam footage
will be released tony omar thank you
very much
that's what they keep talking about the
need for the proper training
you see what happened the day before
when they sent a mental health
professional it worked out all right
yeah well i admire patrick warren
junior's calm
demeanor in this i would be just
outraged i'm sure he is
as well but but and they're so it's so
important that they are
putting all of this out there and
sharing it because this should not have
happened
no mental health is is health if you
were having another
a different medical emergency they would
have sent a specialist they wouldn't say
we don't have anybody sorry fix your own
leg
yeah but because it's the mind they
treat it differently and also can we
point out he clearly appeared to be
unarmed
yeah he clearly was unarmed no i mean
why did the officer go back to the house
after yeah